argentina champion the cup is at home
there is lautaro martínez greeting
all the fans who could reach
the end it ended up overflowing a
little bit they listen in the background
we are not going to run the noodle di maría at the
bottom of everything together with that is the author
of lemon
and in my second I believe with all the
delegation and the fans who ended
up coming here
[Music]
the microphone of the aggregation that enters
the AFA premises returns the cup to
Argentina the cup is at home the cup
is with month and  Finally, the cup
is with month and the soccer joy returned
and there is the reception of
the buses with
chopped paper like the reception
yesterday when Messi raised the cup,
this rain of
little pieces of paper and fireworks is not something traditional
[Music]
and the fans  that explode
we are leaving that step and driving
the step eta and messi sitting next to
us we sensed that we sensed that they need in
the first micro on the
right side for  as for how we see the
movement also of the fans of the
follow-up as always punctually to the
first of the two groups it will not be
that it will be on that side to me yes of course of
course of course they are very close to
reaching the bridge yes to what is the
connection with  from the richter and with the
ezeiza cañuelas highway and after
there they will have to do is a little curl they
will have to go up doing the curl and
then do the last meters up
here to the gate of the
AFA property where we have already seen it and we have
Counting what is expected is one poster or several,
in reality there are three in total the
posters but they are the same with the photo of
Leo Messi of the noodle di Maria- of the kun
aguero of the Diu Martinez one of the
new one of the new idols of the
selection and  step and of course
well strained exactly what they say today they
became heroes
the legendary phrase of mascherano that he
said to chiquito romero in the 2014
argentinian senior team thank you
champions of am  Erica say the posters
and it is signed by the management
Claudio Tapia and the staff
of the AFA property and there is also the
giant inflatable Copa América that
we also saw a while ago and that
you told the details of this producer from La
Plata who was in charge of making it
So we assume that what was left of
the organization that was later
truncated from the Copa América here in our
country will have remained from there the great
celebration requested especially for this
match, well, we will surely know those details
very soon while
we wait and see how the fans
They receive and greet the champions of
America after a wait that lasted 28 years 28
years waiting for this moment,
surely many of the fans who
are there have never seen the
champion team, some will remember when they were
younger